IN THE COVID-19 PANDEMIC FROM AN
EDUCATION MEMO.
AND HERO JONATHAN TURLEY, AND
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
NOW CLAIMS HE HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO CANCEL THE STUDENT LOANS
CITING THIS LAW AND THEN THE
COVID-19 PANDEMIC.
BUT DOES HE?
>> WELL, IT IS A LITTLE CURIOUS
OF AN ARGUMENT ASIDE THE HEROES
ACT, BECAUSE THEY ARE CITING A
CRISIS THAT IT MAY THEY SAID HAD
DIMINISHED TO THE POINT THAT IT
WOULD CHANGE THE STATUS OF
TITLE 42 ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER
THAT THEY CITED THE CDC VIEW OF
THE LESSENING OF THE CRISIS AS A
BASIS AND CORE FOR THAT
ARGUMENT, SO NOW IT IS EXTREMELY
DUBIOUS TO ARGUE THAT THAT ACT
GIVES THE PRESIDENT THE RIGHT TO
BASICALLY TOSS ASIDE
$300 BILLION, AS MUCH AS THAT IN
STUDENT LOANS.
AND YOU KNOW, EVEN IF THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD SOME SUCCESS
INITIALLY, IT IS GOING TO FIND A
FAIRLY CHILLY RECEPTION BEFORE
THE SUPREME COURT.
WHICH HAS REALLY BEEN DEMANDING
CLARITY ON THESE ISSUES, NOT THE
DELEGATION OF CONGRESS TO THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCHES.
AND WHAT IS WEIRD IS THAT THE
DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS ARE
APPLAUDING THEIR OWN
INSTITUTIONAL OPERATIONS.
THEY ARE ALL GIVEN ACCOLADES TO
THE PRESIDENT FOR CIRCUMVENTING
CONGRESS BECAUSE HE KNOWS THAT
HE COULD NOT GET THIS THROUGH
CONGRESS.
>> Laura: NANCY PELOSI HAS
SOMETHING INTERESTING TO SAY
ABOUT THE PLAN JUST A YEAR AGO.
>> PEOPLE THINK THAT THE
PRESIDENT ON THE UNITED STATES
HAS THE POWER FOR DEBT
FORGIVENESS.
HE DOES NOT.
HE CAN POSTPONE, HE CAN DELAY,
BUT HE DOES NOT HAVE THAT POWER.
THAT HAS TO BE AN ACT OF
CONGRESS.
>> Laura: JONATHAN, WHAT
CHANGED?
THAT IS IN COMMUNION.
>> YOU KNOW IT IS AMAZING IS
JAMES MADISON TRULY BELIEVES
THAT EACH OF THE BRANCHES WOULD
JEALOUSLY DEFEND THEIR OWN
AUTHORITY AND EVEN IF THIS WAS A
MEMBER OF YOUR OWN PARTY IN THE
WHITE HOUSE THAT MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS WOULD ASSERT THEIR
INSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS INCLUDING
THAT KEY POWER OF THE FIRST.
THAT IS WHAT IS SO BAFFLING
ABOUT THE POSITION HERE,
PRESIDENT OBAMA DID THE SAME
THING.
WENT TO THE STATE OF THE UNION
AND TOLD CONGRESS IT WAS
CIRCUMVENTING THEM BECAUSE THEY
WOULD NOT GIVE HIM WHAT HE
WANTED AND HALF OF CONGRESS ON
THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE APPLAUDED
HIM.
FOR TURNING THEM INTO ENTITIES.
SO THIS IS REALLY A GREAT
STRETCH, THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
PREVIOUSLY REJECTED THIS BASIS
FOR CANCELING OF LOANS, BUT ALSO
THE NATIONAL --
THE HIGHER EDUCATION ACT MAKES
IT VERY CLEAR THAT CONGRESS
ALLOWS FOR THE POSTPONEMENT OF
DEBT, BUT THEY EXPECTED TO BE
PAID.
>> Laura: POSTPONEMENT, NOT
CANCELLATION, ALL OF